c'est quoi le microbiote intestinal
exactement là et oui parce qu'on entend
souvent parler du microbiote mais on
sait pas vraiment ce que c'est
d'ailleurs quand je dis le microbiote je
devrais dire le microbiote intestinal
parce que des microbiotes on en a
plusieurs dans la bouche dans le vagin
pour les personnes qu'en possèd un et
puis donc dans les intestins l'intestin
grê qui est juste là à la sortie de
l'estomac et le colon juste après et
donc là-dedans c'est plein de bactéries
mais pas seulement il y a aussi des
virus des champignons et puis d'autres
trucs comme les arqués ou les protistes
qu'on connaît moins mais qui sont
importants aussi bon mais on va appeler
tout ça des microbes ces microbes on en
a 100000 milliards dans les intestins
c'est énorme c'est beaucoup plus que nos
propres cellules ils ont 400 m carré de
surface habitable vous avez compris le
microbiote c'est un vrai truc c'est même
parfois considéré comme un organe à part
entière donc ça pèse dans le game au
total notre microbiote intestinal c'est
2 kg de microbe c'est-à-dire autant que
le poids de notre peau et plus lourd que
notre cœur qui pèse à peu près 300 g ou
que notre cerveau qui atteint
péniblement 1,5 et encore pas chez tout
le monde mais je veux pas donner de